bonjour bonjour à ceux qui nous
rejoignent pour cette deuxième partie de
la voie libre consacré aujourd'hui au
premier bilan des six mois de la grande
région bourgogne franche comté avec vous
paierez car oui avec nos trois invités
la présidente socialiste du conseil
régional marie-guite dufay et de
représentante de l'opposition catherine
vandriesse pour la droite et le centre
et sophie montel pour le groupe front
national à lampard et avant les flashs
régionaux de 10 vote du 24 juin
on a vu qu'ils auraient sans doute un
vote territoriale on va dire on va
appeler ça comme ça pour la droite à
votre retraite politique pour le front
national
vous c'est encore vous ne l'avez pas dit
pour le vote politique pour le nombre de
gauche plus globalement est ce que vous
n'avez pas un problème avec cette faible
majorité 51 élus seulement contre 49
pour l'opposition
est-ce que du coup vous n'êtes pas
soumise aux caprices d'untel ou d'untel
avec soyons clairs je préférerais avoir
une majorité plus importante c'est
évident et vous savez la difficulté ça
soude aussi et je vous le redis de quoi
merci patrick molinoz du prg qui vous a
empêché des traînées au premier père
écoutait patrick molinoz moi je veux
bien qu'on en parle beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup sur ce qui s'est passé au mois
de janvier mais il a maintenant écouter
jusqu'à maintenant on travaille de façon
extrêmement placide constructive je lui
ai confié une responsabilité très
importante non seulement autour de la
défense de la laïcité mais autour de la
construction du numérique et de notre
réseau qui doit permettre d'adapter
notre territoire effectivement à la
révolution numérique
il est voilà il fait ce qu'il a à faire
et assume ses responsabilités je n'ai
absolument pas m'en plaindre donc cette
majorité
effectivement elle est faible mais c'est
une contrainte supplémentaire
elle est soudée oui mais on peut
toujours voir les contraintes puis voir
aussi les avantages et les opportunités
moi je suis d'une nature a toujours voir
ce qui est positif et je vois que j'ai
une majorité qui jeunes qui renouveler
car convient et qui est solide
concrètement le 24 juin vous dit on va
avoir dans votre groupe
un vote politique c'est à dire que vous
aurez les cinquante et une voix pour
vous écoutez je suis en train d'y
travailler n 24 s'est pas encore tout de
suite
jour est un jour de construction
politique est toujours ce rejet et il
n'est pas blanc contrairement à ce que
vous me disiez tout à l'heure et hors
essence et internet
mais je pense que là dans la révélation
de madame buffet sera la difficulté des
dix jours à venir c'est bien le problème
régulièrement je ne m'en sentais pas
bien et kurt et je parle de la mise en
place des réformes importantes elles
sont longues
c'est ce que vous nous avez donc cette
fusion était compliquée vous n'avez pas
la conduire réellement alors vous êtes
dessus depuis 18 mois et puis vous allez
majorité qu'il est difficile parce que
les shows laisseront dindinaud les
difficultés à la normale majorité le 24
juin la majorité vous aurez avec le
front national sur cette question et la
manière dont vous allez la négocier une
partie des élus droite et seraient
probablement une partie des élus droite
oui je voulais dit là dessus en erreur
on est extrêmement clair donc une riva
qu'il est plus important de se dire et
pendant ce temps là c'est bien ce que ce
sera une fille et pendant ce temps là
que faites-vous sur le plan de l'emploi
et je ne mangeais la division escaut
yosi une seconde
la dalle est justement est une question
de patrick qui dit les promesses et bien
où en est ma dame du fait dans ses
créations d'emplois je le cite il
faudrait pas quand même mettre dix ans
alors je le répète au niveau des
créations d'emplois aujourd'hui on a un
double problème un chômage structurel
qui n'est pas spécial à la franche comté
mais qui est à la voix grave et qui est
d'autant plus important qu'en bourgogne
comme en franche-comté lounge en
bourgogne comme en franche comté nous
sommes des terres industrielles ou là
effectivement les questions du chômage
sont plus présentes
d'ailleurs il ya un autre problème qui
est aussi important c'est les
entreprises qui n'arrivent pas à
recruter et aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train d'étendre à toute la région cette
mesure qui est applaudi depuis des
années en franche comté et qui consiste
à financer des formations dans les
entreprises pour des demandeurs d'emploi
et à 10 on trouve est en sensible et
adapté forma soit ciblée donc
ça fait honte yonne c'est en train
d'être étendue depuis le vote du budget
du mois d'avril
donc c'est une mesure extrêmement
concret deuxièmement il ya un problème
c'est dans notre région comme partout en
france avec l'investissement notamment
dans le bâtiment et les travaux publics
qui vais tendre qui dépendent fidèlement
de la commande publique et donc là nous
avons fait le maximum
d'une part pour faire accélérer des
travaux routiers notamment sur l'acte
tellement important en bourgogne est
très très insécures s'appelle ar ceeac
lax mon sens digoin acquise en direction
de moulins
c'est un acte très insécures ou là nous
avons nous permis mais n'avance de des
millions pour que l'état aille plus vite
dans la réalisation de ces travaux
nous mettons en place pour le bâtiment
un plan d'investissement local pour que
dans les communes des travaux qu'on pas
pu être faits qui sont dans les tuyaux
mais pour lesquelles il manque un petit
peu d'argent nous amenions cet argent et
que ces trois vos travaux la soif et 258
au total 1 pour nous allons injecter de
l'argent aussi pour le développement du
numérique notamment la très vite dans
l'yonne dans la haute-saône
c'est extrêmement affairés pour yves
lavoie fait réagir votre opposition
madame ont-elles vous avez demandé la
parole
j'écoute madame du fait j'entends dans
la même musique quelle qu'elles nous
jouons schématiquement deux pays ce
n'est pas des mannequins créée par les
deux faits comme à chaque fois vous
faites abstraction de quelque chose qui
me paraît essentiel c'est le contexte
national
on a l'impression que la franche comté
et la bourgogne franche comté c'est un
peu un monde à part et tout alors que
c'était très bien comme moi que nous
subissons directement
les dégâts occasionnés par les
politiques mises en place au niveau
national par le gouvernement socialiste
vous parlez de l'investissement pour les
travaux publics pour soutenir le btp
vous savez goût juste le titre dit que
le btp était dans une crise très grave
selon madame du fait je vais vous redire
moi aussi
pour la énième fois la même chose
comment allez-vous pouvoir développer
l'emploi local la priorité local où la
priorité régionale alors que vous avez
vous revu vos collègues au parlement
européen notamment ont voté ce qu'on
appelle la directive dite des
travailleurs détachés vous savez que
c'est le noeud du problème
c'est l'essentiel du problème qui
rencontrait par les gens du btp en
dehors des avances de trésorerie ça
c'est autre chose mais en tout cas c'est
un problème essentiel est bien
évidemment vous n'avez aucun levier de
commande pour la zone et au niveau
national vos dirigeants enfin le
gouvernement socialiste n'est jamais
revenu sur cette directive au niveau
local ce qui est nécessaire de faire
pour qu'effectivement les entreprises
recrutent le plus possible effectivement
du personnel vous faites comment vous
mettez en club vous envieront bientôt
nous avons des clauses
effectivement nous avions des clauses
qui permettent l'emploi maximal des
personnes qui sont qui sont
effectivement le cas représentants et le
zinc des médias l'outil selon madame
montel nous avons une technique
d'allotissement que nous sommes maîtres
d'ouvragé mais nous ne sommes pas
toujours maître et nous sommes presque
jamais mettre l'une brad mais comme
quand nous sommes maîtres d'ouvragé nous
avons une technique d'un lotissement
pour permettre des petits lots qui
permettent aux entreprises locales de
minime de se présenter pour le reste
nous travaillons avec la profession
aujourd'hui il ya la triche travaillons
avec la profession une charte de bonne
conduite pour permettre le maximum
d'expression et de travail des
entreprises ou environnementale dans les
cégeps de la région et en barges cette
fonction nous dit madame du feu baptême
du feu fait toujours des déclarations
mais dans la réalité pratique du monde
de l'entreprise que là par contre je
connais peut-être effet mais vous allez
tenez vous en buvez en exil a été posté
le train en crète simonet s'est terminée
sur le recrutement oui vous avez raison
il ya un décalage entre le marché du
travail et l'offre entre les demandes et
l'offre est aujourd'hui nous sommes un
certain nombre
elle recherchait des personnels
qualifiés avec des emplois en cdi sans
avoir de solution nous avons voté un
budget important et nous avons de cette
attribution sujet de ce délai la raison
entre autres sur les dotations qui ont
été faites pour la création des
formations des 500 amis le demandeur
d'emploi aujourd'hui très concrètement
comment les choses se passent sur le
terrain des filières ne sont pas
sollicités
il ya des organismes comme les chambres
de commerce par exemple ou pôle emploi
qui à la lecture de ce qui s'est passé
dans dans l'histoire c'est à dire dans
les deux trois quatre dernières années
se disent peut-être que il y à des
domaines de compétences où il ya eu des
besoins parce que nous avons fait des
formations ya trois ou quatre ans donc
ils mettent en place des plans de
formation et il sollicite ensuite les
figures pour savoir s'il ya de besoin
est-ce que vous couvrez ce que vous
croyez en allah vous y attendent
non ce n'est pas carrément disait
absolument jarry qu'elle dans la
pratique de reparler d'une mesure des
bleus départ des logements décidé
aujourd'hui le problème sur
l'apprentissage et la formation
c'est effectivement le décalage
important structurelles pour 60 70 % des
demandeurs d'emploi entre leur qualité
de formation
en tout cas les déformations glee sont
aujourd'hui on peut en capacité de
disposer les demandes sur le terrain et
à aucun moment depuis la mise en place
de ce plan il n'ya eu un état d'urgence
un état d'urgence de rapprochement des
filières professionnelles les biens a
fort mal sinon atterri sur place pour le
nom adam pour le plan gouvernemental
voulue par le président de la république
nous avons mis en place des
consultations avec l'île de ré filles et
madame vous êtes chef de file de
l'opération entend par son financement
l'état d'urgence entre le monde du
travail des filières professionnelles et
les quelle était la formation à la
formation amusant à mettre en place
ça ça n'a pas été fait deuxièmement sur
les simplifications administratives
tout le monde le revendique tout le
monde le sait est ce que vous savez
depuis simplement six mois aujourd'hui
plus d'un chef d'entreprise plus la
jeune entreprise responsable prend la
responsabilité de rédiger lui-même un
bulletin de salaire
abu saleh
m j'ai siégé pendant plusieurs années au
conseil national de simplification de la
vie des entreprises
donc j'ai fait le maximum pour faire
avancer les choses
le problème c'est qu'au nom mais je dis
que je n'ai pas la prétention de
résoudre les problèmes nationaux
j'essaye de voir au niveau local ce que
nous pouvons faire est ce problème
d'adéquation entre les besoins des
entreprises et les compétences des
demandeurs d'emploi il va pas être
résolue comme ça d'un coup de baguette
magique
c'est pour ça qu'il est important
d'impliquer tout le monde professionnel
nous travaillons je crois que c'est une
des régions qui travaille le mieux avec
le monde consulaire la convention que
nous avons avec le monde consulaire qui
représente les entreprises est une
convention qui au niveau national est
jugé extrêmement intéressante
nous nous appuyons sur les forces vives
effectivement pour connaître les besoins
nous nous ne faisons pas cela en chambre
d'accord et vous madame mais vous savez
les fonds de compétences ou dix ans les
entreprises qui sont sur des niches avec
gréement du 200 m c'est pas je n'ai rien
contre eu monde consulaire dont je vous
ai demandé économiques évoluent évolué
de manière très rapide et c'est
réactivité le politique ne la parle
c'est pour rire nous avons mis en place
sont régionales parce qu'il est pro
actif dès qu'une entreprise a besoin
nous amenons d'un financement une petite
conclusion parce qu'il reste moins de 2
minutes 30 secondes chacun
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
région l'as se construit quand même au
bout de six mois mesdames j'ai
l'impression que les régions la
construction de la région bien sûr est
travaillée sera compliqué moi ce qui
m'embête dans tout ça c'est là le même
énerve pragmatique de la proche de la
politique il faut qu'on sorte des cadres
existants
il faut qu'on sort des schémas il faut
qu'on arrive réellement à une à une et
des politiques opérationnelles réels
proches du terrain ça aujourd'hui la
gouvernance ne permet pas sophie bottai
sophie monter vos petits mots de contis
d'olivier c'est ce que j'ai dit en
introduction d'ailleurs c'est qu'il ya
des problèmes de dysfonctionnement
administrés
tic ça c'est inhérent au fait d'avoir
fusionné deux régions ça se retrouve
dans d'ailleurs dans toutes les régions
qui ont fusionné
c'est un aspect mais il ya évidemment
l'aspect politique qui tend à démontrer
qu effectivement il y a il y a encore
une fois des choix qui ne correspondent
pas à ce que de toute façon enfin que
nous aurions mis en place si nous avions
été à la tête de l'exécutif donc voilà
il ya il ya le débat politique et
l'opposition politique est la seule
opposition comme toujours celle du front
national parce que socialiste
marie-guite dufay vous nous annoncez un
plan de mandat et un premier vrai budget
la fin de l'année c'est pas une année
perdue donc 2016 absolument pas et déjà
d'avoir pu rassembler 2 budget il réside
le garantit le mois d'avril nous fait
nous allons mettre en place une
conférence sociale à l'automne pour voir
comment nous pouvons encore plus trouver
des moyens de protection pour tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui trinquent de toutes les
difficultés économiques que nous avons
et je compte sur les acteurs culturels
c'est un message que je veux envoyer
aussi pour petit à petit construire
cette grande région et cette identité
bourgogne franche comté la culture pour
moi va être un levier extrêmement
important de rencontres de partage entre
bourgogne france comté très bien merci
mesdames d'avoir participé à cette
émission mais syrie merci de votre
attention et puis donc on va suivre tout
ça le 24 juin au revoir qui votent
comment au conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté montsalvy à tous au revoir